the show there's fairies creatures
humans coexisting Orlando how do you
explain if a friend says to you carnival
row what's it about how do you explain
it to them in a concise way I actually
it was interesting because when I was
sort of mentioning the fairy aspect of
it the Fae folk they were like grow
berries I was like yeah but these guys
are like cage fighting prostitutes and
and and cage fighting prostitutes yeah
there's a more much more than that
there's a location on the set called the
Teta brie hotel which is a brothel for
the humans to go and frequent and if you
don't do if you if you go to the
activation by the way guys you will see
the Teta brie Hotel there and it's a
very wing very cool this one's eyes like
what happens what she's looking at me
and look at that she's got that's
incredible that's actually yeah it's
cranly a camera so that everyone can see
what she's doing
I have to say watching comment like that
is real dedication the greatest thing
about coming to comic-con is seeing how
the fans just embrace ya know people
have you can be real you can be yourself
you can be anything that woman had her
eyes permanently changed Jags this week
she can't buy a diamond for you she made
love to a rainbow cara maybe you can
explain something to me you play a
badass fairy what is it that makes you
you think I have a badass cuz that's
rude yeah I am in no position to
criticize anyone's ass but anyway but
what is it that what would you say that
makes you cool makes you badass um I
would be boy I mean that's a good reason
to thank you let's see uh she's she's
just you know we've all been through it
she's uh she's been knocked down many
many times that she just refuses to give
up she's a survivor she's a warrior but
she also worries she has a huge heart
and she just never gives up you know she
wants the best to everyone even the
people that her her she wants empathy
and to understand why people do the
things they do she's a fighter but she's
a fighter of love so that's why she's
and these there's a there's there's a
lot of these fairies getting on is that
a fair thing to say they these fairies
so there's a like what like that's
cutting it off yeah yeah they rode a
rowboat across the canal yeah
oh you know I'm tired no this one seems
silly when they can fly why don't I take
a boat when you can throw yeah no they
definitely get it on but I yeah they're
what I'd say most areas are kind of
pansexual because the the Fae generally
they love you know without gender so
they are I'm a pansexual fairy nice to
meet you yeah what happens when they
generally what what what I know I don't
understand even what happens in when
humans do it but I can teach you it's
called the birds and the bees okay
no I love it if you gave me lesson but I
could teach you a lot I say skip that
okay but I'm just curious when when when
humans and fairies get together crazy
things happen right well certainly in
the Tessa brie hotel I mean oh we have a
love story and it's a very beautiful
love story we have a love but I think in
the in the brothel there are some
interesting things that can happen with
a human and and wings levitating and
also they'll be having sex and then
they'll they'll both lift up into the
air the ferry will take the human up
into the air while they're consummating
their lives yeah kind of the best sort
of give them a ride you know you're
going to the Tessa P Hotel get a good
ride and you get my flags he's got
nothing on the tattoo brie hotel tape
that to you but 13 flags is it six flags
no no listen okay all right well where
did you make this you made it in Prague
and this is all by the way
[Applause]